You're like ghosts!
Oh, everybody, did you see that?
Did you see that?
Isn't that kind of nifty?
Did you see it?
Yeah, hold on.
I'll do it again, I'll do it again.
Woo!
Yay!
I have a little transition stinger now.
Isn't that cute?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna save a...
I don't know.
I was like, I don't know.
I'll just start using it today.
I like different today.
Nope, I'm still the same.
Thank you guys for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you all.
Thank you.
Oh, I didn't...
Wait, did I say...
Did I welcome you home?
I think so.
Wait.
You did.
I'm a wee bit nervous.
There's a lot going on today, you guys.
There's so many things happening today.
So, today's stream will be...
That's, it'll be about the normal length of a reveal.
So, yeah, it's exciting.
I don't want to keep you guys held up here, right?
So, but after the reveal, I want to do a little bit of karaoke.
I have just a couple songs.
I already picked them out too.
And then, I also want to show you guys a preview of something.
So if you stick around to the very end, you will see.
You will see.
I'll challenge.
My drink is burning me.
Yes, yes, yes.
So, mmm, mmm, mmm.
I don't...
I don't really know what to say.
Or do.
I... This is my first proper outfit reveal, so I'm kind of like...
I'm so...
What do I do?
I'm nervous, I'm nervous!
But, um...
And also...
Thank you guys!
for 400k thank you thank you thank you thank you I really really appreciate it thank you so much and I make very excited about this outfit I think it's very very cute and yeah I hope you guys like it too I think artists will be very It's extremely easy.
It's, you know, sometimes simple is best, right?
So it's very easy to draw.
And I can take clothes off.
So, um...
So, if you don't want to even draw some of all of it, you can just take stuff off and draw that, too.
Don't blush.
Stop.
It's summer.
It's summer and, you know, it gets a little hot.
So, it's just got, you know, sometimes you guys never strip?
Permission to drop in without clothes.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Thank you.
I can't wait to cosplay this boss.
Yeah!
Should be very easy for cosplayers too.
I mean, of course, it's, you know, comfy.
I'm finally able to take off my main uniform.
After five long years.
Thank you guys so much for all the gifts.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
I don't, I can't, I can't, I don't have time to say thank you to individually everybody right now.
But thank you.
all the super chats thank you thank you for that go super imagine the smell i think i still do a good job at keeping myself minty fresh i'd say i'd say that i um look that's today right now we'll we'll we'll uh we'll mosey over you know when uh In, like,
one minute.
Also, don't tell me to hurry up.
Gotta build the hype.
Come on.
Right, we gotta build the excitement of, like, oh my gosh.
Also, I'm gonna...
Wait.
I just realized I'm taking you to my room.
Because I've never been to my room before.
Wait, now I'm...
Now I'm even more nervous!
I didn't clean!
But it's clean.
Well, it's like a little abandoned.
But you know, I mean...
I just don't like haunting with people, you know what I mean?
If I accidentally spook them, they'll be like, And then I'm like, So...
It's just, uh, it's just easier to choose someplace abandoned, right?
That makes sense.
Yeah, see?
Shall we, shall we blow this popsicle stand?
Shall we?
Go home for real?
Well, it's my home.
It's not your, you, unless you pay rent.
Unless you pay Ray
Let's Let's Let's Mousy Hold on I'm gonna Oh
good evening Good evening Good evening Good evening Good evening Welcome to my abode Don't mind the You guys know how I've talked about having like on my wall and stuff i mean it's let me give you the grand tour yay my room look i have this cute little dino plushie on my bed so cute and i'm so vain i have this picture of myself on the wall just you know gotta it's honestly like kind of a dominant thing for ghosts to say like hey someone's here but out you know so and then i have gangard here i have gangard yeah i love plushies i have so many plushies sorry and i have koharu she's right above me yeah koharu watches over me in my sleep and my switch which i will be using today for karaoke so I needed to get it out and up and ready and I got like cute little lights and everything it's so cozy no and you don't mind the metal gear things on the table and oh you guys
you're a big squishy and fat been feeding you well just kidding it's not actually you it's a plushie
Yeah, isn't it a bit windy?
Oh, do you feel it draft?
Or I would close the window, but it's actually broken.
Yeah, don't bind.
Don't bind.
Don't mind.
But this is my room, and now I'm just going to kick it back.
I'm going to take my shoes off.
I'm going to get cozy, comfy.
Is that okay?
Oh, I just realized I don't really have refreshments to give you guys.
Uh...
But you'll be fine, right?
It's a really cozy room, you think so?
Nah, I'm gonna get cozy too now.
And so, um...
I guess I'll go do that.
Go get cozy.
But no peeking.
No...
No peeking.
Okay?
i'm gonna change but like and i know you're probably extremely excited to be in a girl's room but it's just try and be a gentleman for two seconds okay try try
i'll be right back
give me like a minute to get prepared Oh, I'm so scared!
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm getting dressed up.
Wait.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alrighty.
Well, guys.
You know, actually, there is one thing I want to do.
Because when I'm like...
When I'm getting...
When I'm getting comfy, cozy...
I'm just going to pretend that you guys are not here.
Is that okay?
One thing that I like to do, now that I'm all like changed and just feeling trying to relax, wind down after a busy day at the maid cafe, I think I'm going to write a little bit.
You don't mind, right?
You guys can just kind of do your own thing.
And I'm going to write a little bit.
But I want some, I want some suggestions if you don't mind.
So, let's see.
Okay.
Wait, that's not what I meant to do.
Don't, don't, don't, wait, don't react to that.
Wait, how do I stop this?
What?
Wait, what is this feature?
Ah!
Wait!
Okay, one moment.
Here we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
What the hell is a Q&A?
Okay, you guys have like 30 seconds to answer.
I see, I see, interesting.
Interesting, interesting.
I'm gonna change the BGM for this.
Wow, that's an overwhelming win.
You guys are freaks or something.
It's time to Yume out.
I mean, that's me every day.
Okay.
Oh, Yume out.
Um, cool.
I don't think it's going to change at all.
So, I will write a fanfic of me and Snake.
Okay.
Gotta get cozy.
Okay, here we go.
Snake, don't forget your bento.
I made it just for you.
I put extra, extra, extra cheese and a calorie mate too.
Snake smirked smirkedly.
Thanks, Minto.
who could cook and clean, which you can definitely do, and you do every day.
Such a great job.
With no mistakes, Minto blushed.
Her blush extending from the tip of her tippy button nose to the tip of her pointy ears.
She was embarrassed.
It had all been one year since Snake left Ocelot, but the thought of them not being together still crosses her mind.
Does he still think of Ocelot?
When they sleep in the same bed?
Oh, but Mint and Snake don't do anything.
They just sleep not doing anything like that anyway does he wish that he was sleeping in the same bed and also uh wait touching oselot but but in a in not in a bad way in like a way that is romantic that will make him happy minto ponders that this is a good start this is a good start to chapter 1 i'd say i'd say this is a good yeah but there but but it needs more workshopping i will continue this i will i will put this in the in my folder that will be continue writing
are we cozy yet are we cozy yet
wow Look at you guys!
Look at you, look how gooey you are.
I finally got to take my shoes off.
And you know, guys, those were heels.
I've been wearing like heels for quite some time now.
So, it's finally, it feels so good to finally be able to just, yeah, put my slippers on.
I wear slippers all the time.
Like I'm never not wearing slippers, you know.
you guys see it all you guys see you guys getting comfy and what's this what's a tail what what that you how did you how could you you probably couldn't tell that it was a tail from the silhouette uh uh uh Uso!
Uso!
Yeah, I'm like good on my tippy toes too.
Where does it come from?
Well, I do have a reference that I will show you all.
Yes.
The only bounce Minto has?
Honestly, I think Celia probably was just like well I'm not I'm not rigging boobs so you guys this is the jiggle physics isn't this what you came for the vtuber jiggle physics yes yes yes but let's I still feel like riding though you guys I still feel like riding I'm trying to really get into my into my cozy comfort feeling you know now that I'm home and all that so um let's see what let's let's write something else let's write something else so what should I write let's see same
as before same as before.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, my legs.
Well, you guys can normally see my legs, I think.
I think you guys can normally see my legs, though.
Oh!
You saw nothing?
There we go.
I'll zoom in a little bit.
Oh.
So what should I write?
about we have three options write in my diary right about how cute my oh she is or write about akihabara hmm decisions decisions decisions
decisions decisions but i think how cute my oh she is is it's another overwhelming win it's crazy
all right all right that's your oshi smirk smirkedly i will then write about my oshi this will definitely get my creative juices flowing that but yeah yeah i should reconsider that phrasing okay anyway it's not like that it's not like that okay whatever i'm gonna write about my because she's so cute okay guys do you ever just fall in love do you ever look at someone for the first time and think wow we they are just the greatest most beautiful most amazing most wonderful most cutest most spectacular being you've ever seen in this world in this universe well that's how i feel about myoshi myoshi is the cutest girl ever to ever exist she does many cute things like pose with her hands and she has a big old smile and she does many cute faces if you ever saw her would fall in love too.
Sometimes when she sees me, she touches my hand.
And sometimes when she sees me, she is just very cute.
Actually, that's every time she sees me.
She is always cute.
If I get amnesia, I would be happy because I could meet her again all over for the first time and experience the feeling of falling in love all over again.
She is my soul Oshi, and I would find her in any incarnation.
Is that right?
I love my Oshi.
The end.
Yep, pretty much that.
Pretty much that.
Yeah, pretty much.
Yeah.
Do you guys feel that too?
Do you guys feel that way as well, Masuroshi?
I'd say.
It's a very strong bond I have with me and myoshi.
I would find her in every timeline.
I'd say.
And...
Boom!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Big puppy jacket!
Big, big jacket!
And she's got shorts on!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa!
I'm so pink, right?
I think, I think, I am-y mama.
Made this outfit...
When I saw it, I was just like...
It kind of looks like I borrowed her wardrobe.
It kind of feels like I borrowed her wardrobe a little bit.
But also...
Also...
Let's see.
I'll zoom in just a tiny tad bit.
Because...
There's, of course, something very important.
Maybe.
Perhaps.
You know, of course if it...
Let me...
I mean,
it's breezy in here, but it's still summer, no!
So, I just thought it would be...
Just thought it might be good to...
To, you know...
To take it on!
There you guys go.
Oops, don't look.
There you go.
Exactly what you wanted, huh?
Look at that.
I lotioned up, baby.
That's fresh ectoplasm.
Right there.
Enhance, enhance!
So, the tummy
But we'll keep the jacket on for now.
We'll keep the jacket on for now.
Guys, I still want to write more, though.
I want to write more.
Let's do one more.
One more, one more writing prompt.
i think i think right okay okay um okay this one should be easy all right let's see oh
i can't spell this one should be easy okay and pull this is what you do when you're at home and you're you're doing otaku activities you know you watch streams you play games and you write about revolver awesome That's a lot.
Decide, decide, decide!
Rigged!
What do you mean, rigged?
I was like, can you kind of see my hair?
Kind of see my hair.
Peaking out the illusion of choice.
No!
Number three, my lord.
Pick number three, my lord.
No, they're definitely different choices.
Yeah, they're definitely different.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to write about the Revolver Ocelot.
Good choice, everybody.
Good choice.
Revolver Ocelot.
Revolver.
This guy drives me absolutely bonkers!
It is something that's hard for me to describe because it's far beyond love or any admiration i put this man on a pedestal i put him above every human being ever that has been born or existed in this universe revolver also is everything that i wish could be and he is someone that i don't even know how to describe how much this man has changed my brain chemistry how could someone be so the way that they are so unapologetically themselves to such a mad degree that he just does it all i can't i can't describe him perfectly because there's just so much to him he's everything that i want everything i want to be a revolver ocelot just just saying his name shiver down my spine he's such a he's such a powerful powerful force in my afterlife
just this just like the speech make it's and the Ocelot that changed him, his trajectory of his life.
That's how I felt just watching that scene.
I felt the osmosis of afterlife changing.
This, and it happened to me as well, you know, through him.
If I...
If there was one person I could ever possess for the rest of my afterlife and just see a little bit, a little bit of what goes inside their brain, their head, it would be Ocelot.
The end.
I didn't get enough off my chest.
But...
It still felt good.
3!
Boo!
Ghost.
Is that what you thought it would say?
Yay!
I feel so comfy.
So, so comfy.
And I got, I got a cute little, little necklace on.
I got a cute little necklace on.
And, um, of course, I'll show you without the jacket on.
Bada-dum.
Oh!
Don't call it a caller, you freak!
What are you talking about?
Oh, it does jingle a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that also...
You know, sometimes...
Okay, this is like maybe a very specific situation.
But you know when you are sleeping and you are cold but hot at the same time, stick out one leg.
But what if you just, like, stick out your shoulders?
What if I just kind of, like, removed the tank top underneath?
And...
It's just kind of similar to, like, sticking your leg out.
to where you um to where you and it like i said it's it's it's it's it's still summer so it gets warm but it's also it's also quite quite chilly at night so it's nice to have a little bit of both i'd say okay i'm embarrassed but also i want to point out this guy look at him go
It makes me want to eat pudding!
It makes me want to eat pudding.
Yeah.
As for the slippers, I was supposed to have this made as merch, but unfortunately, it did not happen.
But hopefully in the future, you guys can get your very own Wisp slippers.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you can see the ribbons in my hair.
So many ribbons, so many ribbons.
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute.
We got stepped on.
Yeah, I'm stepping on you.
Akidoki!
Wait, is this it?
Is this the final reveal?
Is this...
You see my face and that's it?
And then...
Oh, oh!
No, right.
Okay.
I'm just gonna tear the Band-Aid off Which is what I have underneath my tank top Why did I say that?
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh, I didn't...
Okay.
Three, two, one!
I think someone is here.
Give me...
One second!
Hold on, let me just answer the door real quick.
Let me just...
I answer the door.
What?
Give me a second.
Oops!
Wait, I just messed up.
Wait, one moment!
Sorry.
One second!
Oh my gosh, this is like the the longest delivery ever!
What?
What the heck?
What is this long delivery?
I have so many things I need to sign.
Everything I need to sign.
Oh, there's doing their due diligence i suppose of of things for me this just oops oops oops everything is oops everything is oops everything is oops everything is oops what am i doing there we go
dokey dokey
okay okay we got it we got it we got it we got it we got it
It's me!
I'm the package.
Oh, you gotta.
Did you...
Did you ask for a package?
Wait.
Is that the set?
Did you...
Okay.
I'm just kidding.
Three,
three, two, one!
Ta-da!
Oh, that's a beat.
Ah, that's a beat again.
Wait, get rid of the room.
Hey there, nerds.
Hey, nerds.
Um, uh, welcome.
Welcome to my room!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Welcome to my abode!
I'm finally cozy, comfy.
I'm finally cozy, comfy here in my room.
Yippee!
You guys kind of like the old school fujoshi, old school otaku look a little bit.
And then also, like I showed you with the jacket, without the frills, and I showed you the glasses.
But also, also, I can do it with my other hair.
So it's kind of fun to, to, I think actually, actually, like this looks so natural.
Yeah, so I can still have my main headband on.
It's still me, it's still me.
And if I put my braids, if I take my braids out...
Long hair.
Long hair, long hair.
Yay, yay, yay.
I figured, you know, you guys have cat ears.
I kind of want cat ears.
So, I'm here with the ears.
Here with the ears.
But also, I want to do some karaoke.
I said I would.
I want to show you the setup.
I want to show you.
Nerd!
Today I pick songs that are extremely like, if you're a otaku, you know these songs.
Or, oh, let me show you as well.
Let me show you.
Oh, it's huge.
Sorry, I didn't get it set up.
Ta-da!
Reference sheet.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I think the back of the tank top is so cute, too.
The camera's so...
So, yeah, very easy, right?
Very easy.
simple easy to draw
reference reference sheet minkitty real minkitty real tammy yeah have a tail and where's the tail
hmm anyway okay i have i have songs i want to sing so i'm gonna let's see i think it's like about here and then i go bam bam thank you ma'am boom and i go boom
welcome to my room
i got a keyboard it looks as It's like the keyboard that, um, that Barrett gave me.
So, yeah, so cute.
Very similar.
And, um, I got a, I got the biggest cup of coffee you've ever done seen in your entire life and or afterlife.
Like, I'm, I'm wired, you guys.
I, well, that's.
It's good to have a big cup of coffee for those late night anime binges.
And sometimes I have to wake up early if I want to get idle tickets or get idle merch.
It's good to have a big coffee for it.
It's one cup.
One, one cup.
Yeah, it's as big as your head.
I guess I could have soup in it.
Coffee soup.
I can't...
Yeah, I guess I could have coffee in it.
Yeah, I mean soup.
Soup in it.
It's a bowl of coffee.
Look how yummy it is.
Shall we sing?
One character that kind of inspired my outfit Was Narusegawa Naru From Love Hina Oh, I forgot to set up my Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, hold on One moment, please I forgot to set up the Karaoke Hold on I switch
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
So, you know, you know.
So, I want to sing the first song.
Which, I said, sorry, today's karaoke will probably be incredibly...
Can you hear it?
I just noticed.
Oh, well, you probably can't hear it right now.
Hopefully, you can hear it in, like, two seconds.
Uh.
Can I hear it?
is it playing it's I can't hear it oh one moment is it playing it's gotta be playing cancel cancel the thing oh because it's oh I see why I see why okay okay I see why I see why oh it's probably like oh oh oh Here we go.
That should be good, right?
Is that...
Is that okay?
You hear it?
Okay, cool.
Me too.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
Yeah, I have four ears.
The more to ignore you with my dear.
All the backseating will go through the cat ears, so I kind of Nora butter.
Just in and out, baby.
Let's try.
Sorry.
I'm using the joy sound.
So, joy sound on the switch.
I didn't practice this.
This is going to be probably scuffed, but...
That's so wonderful.
That's so wonderful I can't see I can't see that's the way I want to be I don't want to hear me or
I'll test you to do it So I'm a man, I'm a man, don't fall out
I learned today that this song is composed by the same lady that composed four fruits basket.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
I was like, what?
What is this?
The contrast is crazy.
I'm gonna also Let's get rid of this and This And so I'll sing with my outfit out, like, you can actually see it.
Like, I'll sing like this.
Just singing in my room.
Just singing.
All by myself.
For funsies.
What did I have next?
Oh gosh.
I wrote everything down.
I wrote the wrong thing.
Oh.
This one, probably, they're all going to be scuffed.
I really apologize.
Yeah, I gotta show the wiggle off.
I gotta show the wiggle off.
But also, like, look at my hips.
English.
It's not an English song though.
But we can be a little sexy for this one, I think.
There we go.
Oh.
Yes.
This one.
I realized that a lot of these songs I picked, because they're like Annie's song, I don't know the full versions.
So I Apologize for like the middle.
Here I'll get a little closer.
There we go.
Maybe that's better.
Oh, right in my...
There we go.
Tuna, tuna, tuna, tuna, tuna, tada, tada, tada, tada, yada, yada, yada, yada, yada, yada, yada, yada.
Sweetie darling, let's dance Let's go, beauty lady It's a sweet, sweet, sweet, sweet girl I want to be the best Classmate, the good, the good girl Pink, no, wait, sorry, ah The girl has cute, the blues Oh,
why is it so off-timing?
Oh, because it's so obvious.
Oh, so-called obvious.
Ah, so-bye-bye-bye-bye.
lighten-bye-bye-bye.
My darling, hey, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Na-bye-bye.
Sexy beauty.
Let me just show you what I see.
What the hell?
They're like playing basketball.
Charple, nice, sweety story The heart wick, wick, wick, wick And when the light is light, And when the light came, When I met that night, So, and I came to the end, the unhappiness of the stars The stars extremists' showers And I'm going to pour out And so happy station Go,
50, 50, 50 I can't get over this really Oh, I can't get over this view Oh, couldn't stop the living out deeper
Oh my gosh, sorry, I'm dyslexic a little bit And they're playing basketball!
They're gonna get married to have babies!
My daddy, my daddy,
Oh, this is the primary goes up
I need to stop pretending that I'm sexy.
I need to stop pretending I'm sexy.
It doesn't work!
It doesn't work, everybody.
Okay, next song.
Next song, I definitely know because I sang it recently.
Oh, wait.
I don't want you guys to see it.
I love sexy with fandom.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, nope, that's the wrong.
Kiss.
Cast it!
Thank you guys for the look!
Thank you!
You love sexy Vipayato.
Really?
Was I sexy?
Yubi!
Sadly, I can't do the dance for this, so if you know the dance, do
it.
If you open your heart, open your heart.
Let's move, the voice will be together.
Banana-na-na-na-na.
The bright, bright-n-n-n-n-n-n-na-n-n-n-darkening.
The love you love, I love you.
The win-win-win-win-win-win-win-win-win-win.
Let's go, let's go, let's dance, let's dance One, two, three,
Let's sing, do my best.
I'm
doing the dance, kind of.
I'm doing the dance, kind of.
That was real eyes!
Realize, real eyes, real eyes.
Real, real lies.
Real lies.
I don't know what I'm saying anymore.
Real eyes, real lies.
Real lies.
Real eyes.
Realize.
I forgot to do like facial expressions and stuff.
We can do it with...
with this in the background, I suppose.
Um...
Uh...
They're all the same, though.
Um...
Wait!
This...
goes perfect!
Now!
Why did I tongue them out?
I'm a real cat.
Yeah!
Um, meow.
What do you mean you want to keep seeing my tummy?
You you freaks?
What do you mean?
What do you mean you wish that I could toggle the the the The frills off my tank top off with also the jacket off What do you mean?
That's what you wish to see.
Are you...
Are you satisfied?
Okay.
Layouts I got.
Um...
But in your ear.
That was fun.
That was exciting.
And then, of course, you know.
Would you adopt a mean kitty?
If you saw a mean kitty on the side of the street, would you...
If you saw a mean kitty in a cardboard box, would you say just a box and walk away?
Would you investigate said box and would you adopt mink at him?
I can't cook or clean.
I'm a mid at a mid cafe.
I don't know how to do anything.
So I actually, all I would do is, I'm potty trained though.
I think.
Just a box.
If you write that on the litter box, it would work.
So you would adopt a mean kitty and allow her into your home to claw your furniture and eat your food and haunt your space?
I'm still a ghost.
Ghost.
Promise.
Promise me that you'll give me your credit card and three digits on the back.
You all serious?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yay!
Minkini lives out her...
Well, I really don't need anything.
I'm a ghost.
Minkini lives out her days
comfortable.
need much scratch tower actually you don't even just buy yourself like a tv and i'll take the box you know i'm one of those types of cats my cat uh uh pause she really loves to lay on cardboard on the floor so i have like just little cardboard slab and sometimes she'll like run on it and slide across the floor so yeah yeah yeah you have something you want to say to me You called?
You called?
I'm scared to do this one.
I think it's gonna...
activate somebody.
Especially with the caller.
But I guess I'll do it anyway.
I have it.
This music is...
me out.
This music is taking me out because it's so so silly.
Screenshot.
Shall I sing?
This next one I might also get scuffed because that's one of those songs.
Sorry, I'm so nervous still.
I'm still I'm still so nervous!
And I'm also singing a bunch of new songs, so...
Time to get some Edoge BGM.
But this next one is not from an Edoge, but it is from a show also about Edoge, and I bring out my glasses again, because there's a character in it.
That also wears these same glasses.
Can you guess?
What do you mean, huh?
Do you guys know why I picked my mama?
Oh, I saw someone guess.
Correctly.
Oh, I saw two.
You guys are so smart.
Gosh, I've never sung this song before.
I've listened to it a bajillion times.
like the shortened version of it.
This is Irony by Clarice from Oh, my little girl is so cute
like a lady.
Why is it a sad lady?
Why?
She's so sad.
Don't be YASASICSICS Don't look like me What's it like to do?
I can't see the words I can't see the words Your face I can't
see Where is the place where I've lost the keys I can't find I can't find where I can't find the keys by the way you say, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh You're a little too far My hand's not even I can't even feel the way you're the one and the one,
Don't be so gentle and gentle, don't be there, oh, again, I'll hurt you, but the same thing with the same
Little sisters!
I keep going with the, with the, what's it called?
the following but it's a little oh
and I'm not muted my switch just turned off no it didn't oh
my switch just turned off the thing for the the connector for the switch just just turned off uh oh I think my house is haunted.
Well, I was going to say something.
Oh, also this weekend, this Comiket.
So singing Ore Imo is kind of perfect, no?
Oh, no.
I paid for it.
I'm looking for Joy Sound.
I hope I...
Oh, no.
Well, I only had one.
last song.
I guess I could sing it.
Why?
Hmm.
This alpha is perfect for Kamiket.
Curse of singing Ore Imo.
YouTube's scared.
Don't be scared of Little Sister.
Even though Kuro Neko was best girl.
Okay.
I'm just going to sing my last song.
Sorry.
It was a That was the short version, anime version.
I'm just gonna sing my last song and then I'll call it there, you guys.
So sorry, so sorry.
But thank you so much.
Well, I'm not gonna sing it through the joy sound, I suppose, I'll sing it.
I'll sing it through YouTube.
Wait, if they have it.
We started with the Hayashibara Megumi song.
Now we do.
We end with Hayashibara Megumi song.
Okay!
Give a reason.
Oh my gosh, I just completely forgot.
I'm not afraid of you, but I'm not strong.
I'm just not doing anything to do, I don't want to do anything.
I'm just going to go, go, go, I'm going to keep my life, keep my life in my life.
I'm in my own life, give me a reason for life, I want to know.
Ruby!
Thank you for the breeze!
Can't wait to see your friend.
I'm a reason for life, I'm all topsy-turvy today.
And I hope you guys have liked the outfit.
And yeah, thank you.
Oh, oh, oh shit.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, you're welcome!
Sorry.
Preview time!
Yaza!
For staying till the end.
Thank you!
Wait.
Yaza!
Let me make sure it's the right one.
Okay, wait.
It's...
Ooh, it's gonna be loud.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so...
scuffed um okay uh sorry wait let me try this um actually i'm gonna put you in the intro real quick there we
it won't let me do it unless unless i'm on this page okay i'm just gonna turn it wait i don't know how to do i'm so sorry you guys oh my gosh this is so scuffed
everybody watching the VOD, so sorry for the hiccup.
It definitely was just a few seconds and not a couple of hours.
But for everybody who stayed around and wanted to see the preview, then thank you so much for your patience.
And here you go.
Okay,
you guys were so patient.
Thank you.
Thank
you.
See you later.
Oh my gosh.